Everyone knows there's nothing
quite like a good tearjerker ending,
but did you know Twin Peaks had not one but two?
This list includes a few you might not expect.
Be warned, though: here there be spoilers...
The second and final season of Fleabag proudly
announces in its first episode that it's going
to be "a love story." By the end of the season,
though, you realize that it's not necessarily a
love story with a happy ending. The season's
thrust involves the titular character falling
for a priest, who ultimately decides to
remain devoted to God. In the final scene,
he visits her at a bus stop, and she tells him
that she loves him. His reply is devastating:
"It'll pass."
So in the end, Fleabag doesn't get to be with him,
even though he admits he loves her as well. It's
a terribly sad ending, even when you realize, by
the end, that Fleabag will probably be okay. In a
gesture that suggests the finality of the ending,
she walks away from the camera that's been
following her this entire time. She no longer
needs to share her life with the audience,
and the audience too needs to be okay with it.
The final moments of Six Feet Under were
almost certainly designed in a lab to
completely devastate everyone who loves the
show. As Claire, the baby of the Fisher family,
drives away from the life she's known,
the show transitions to a montage in
which every single one of the show's
recurring characters meet their maker.
It's a perfect summation of death's beauty and
inevitability. The show suggests that each of
its main characters go on to lead meaningful
lives, and then, at some point, pass away — as
all people must. It doesn't treat death as
a cudgel, or as something that only exists
to get an emotional reaction out of viewers.
Instead, Six Feet Under shows death as what it is:
A natural part of being alive. Everything is
temporary, and in the final moments of the series,
the show provides a gut-wrenching
reminder to hold on to what you've got.
Although it's only five episodes long,
Chernobyl nevertheless leaves a huge impact
on its audience. The series tells the story of
the Chernobyl disaster, with particular focus
on the bureaucracy that proved so ineffectual in
dealing with the crisis. In its final episode,
the show depicts the USSR's half-hearted
effort to hold people accountable for this.
Ultimately, a few low-level men inside the
facility are held responsible, while the entire
system that they existed within is ignored. The
lies that were told about the Chernobyl facility,
and the conditions that led the facility
to be unsafe, are not reckoned with at all.
In the end, Valery Legasov, the crusader who
wanted to change how the USSR handles its nuclear
facilities, is revealed to have taken his own
life. He knows that the change he longs for will
not come, that people are much happier living with
the lie. And that is a truth he cannot live with.
Although each series of Blackadder is set in
a different era in history, the show's overall
tone always remains relatively constant. The
show's final season, Blackadder Goes Forth,
places the show's antihero and his supporting
cast in the trenches of World War I.
Because it's a comedy, you might be
tempted to assume that Blackadder
is going to trivialize the grim
nature of the war it's depicting.
But the show takes the opposite approach. In
its final episode, Blackadder and the rest
of the show's characters realize that they
are about to be sent on a suicide mission.
They spend much of the episode attempting
to escape from their fate, but to no avail.
"Good luck, everyone."
In the show's final moments, they charge out of
their trench and are presumably mowed down in
a hail of gunfire. Few shows are bold enough to
kill off their entire main cast in their finale,
but that's precisely what Blackadder does.
The finale was widely acclaimed after
it aired, not just for its bravery,
but also for the ruthlessness with which
it is able to depict the horrors of war.
During World War I, countless soldiers were sent
to die totally meaningless deaths — and Blackadder
is one of the few shows willing
to depict that reality in full.
The final moments of Twin Peaks are anything
but uplifting. Disregarding The Return,
which functions more as a sequel than as
a continuation of the original series,
Twin Peaks' season two finale leaves things in
a pretty dire state for its heroes. Initially,
you're led to believe that Dale Cooper
has managed to enter the Black Lodge,
rescue Annie Blackburn, and return
to the town of Twin Peaks unharmed.
In the show's final moments, however, it
becomes clear that Dale Cooper is no longer
the stand-up FBI agent he was at the beginning of
the series. Instead, he's been corrupted by Bob,
the evil presence at the heart of the town who
is responsible for the death of Laura Palmer.
In the final moments of its original run, Twin
Peaks pulls the rug out from under its audience,
revealing that the show's stalwart hero is
gone, having been replaced by a vision of pure,
unbridled evil. And although Coop
certainly wouldn't be gone forever,
it's not like The Return gave him
much of a happy ending, either...
Veep's ending isn't sad in the
sense that it might make you cry.
Rather, the show devotes its final episode to
the emptiness of politics. As Selina attempts
to win her party's nomination for president, she
reveals that she's willing to sacrifice everyone
and everything she's supposed to care about in
order to get it. She trades away her principles
to earn support from other wings of her party,
and blames Gary, the person who has been at her
side throughout the entirety of the show, for
an FBI investigation into her charity fund.
Selina betrays everyone — and as a
result, she gets exactly what she wants.
Ultimately, though, viewers know
that her victory is a hollow one,
because it comes at the cost of every character
they've grown to love. From its first episode,
Veep presents a world in which what you achieve
as an influential politician matters far
less than how much power you accumulate. In its
finale, Veep doubles down on that brutal theme
and digs into the dark heart of what makes
the American political system so absurd.
The ending of Parenthood is dark in a uniquely
simple way: It focuses on the death of the
Braverman family's patriarch, Zeek. The show's
final moments take place after Zeek's death,
as we see the rest of the Bravermans
assemble to play baseball in his honor.
It's a beautiful, moving tribute that acts as a
reminder of the legacy that Zeek has left behind.
He created the family at the center of the series,
and in its final moments, the show chooses to
spotlight that. Zeek's death is a sad event, but
Parenthood reminds its audience that feeling sad
is just one part of the human experience.
Losing Zeek feels like losing a member of
your family should: It breaks your heart, but it
also gives you a chance to remember all the great
things the person did while they were alive. It's
bittersweet, contemplative, and totally honest.
How do you end a show when your principal
characters have been dead the whole time?
As it turns out, the answer is to kill them
again. In the final episode of The Good Place,
all four core members of the show's human cast
have all finally arrived in the Good Place.
Once there, they're able to fulfill
every desire they've ever had.
Eventually, though, they realize that they're
ready to move on, and essentially phase out of
existence itself. It's a concept that's almost
too heady for TV, but Chidi, ever the professor,
explains it well. Life in The Good Place is
like a wave: Once you crash on the shore,
you disappear, but the water you
leave behind is still very much there.
"The wave was just a different way for
the water to be for a little while."
The Good Place's finale is about learning
to accept the end of your own existence.
Specifically, it's about willingly relinquishing
your identity and becoming a positive force in the
universe. Death isn't the end for the show's
main characters, but in the final episode,
they all blink out of existence for good — in
a way that goes far beyond the mere stopping
point that is physical death. The show makes clear
that they've all accepted this choice, of course,
but that doesn't mean it's
not utterly heartbreaking.
After 11 seasons on the air, no one
expected M*A*S*H to do anything all
that daring in its final episode. The series
finale chronicles the end of the Korean War,
and the party that the members of the camp throw
before they say their tear-filled goodbyes to
one another. Before those farewells happen,
though, the show offers up a meaty plot about
the weight of the conflict, and what it's done
to Hawkeye Pierce, the show's main character.
In this episode, Hawkeye revisits a traumatic
incident that occured as his unit was returning
from a beach outing. Their bus eventually picked
up a number of refugees, but was forced to pull
off the road in order to avoid being spotted.
Hawkeye specifically recalls telling a woman
to quiet her chicken, and the woman killing
the chicken to keep it from making noise.
"Everybody's life was in danger
because of that damn chicken."
Later on in the episode, it's revealed
that Hawkeye has repressed the real memory:
It wasn't a chicken she was trying to keep silent,
but her own baby. The woman smothered her child
in order to survive, and Hawkeye can't cope
with the reality of that memory. It's a dark,
dark turn for the final episode of the show, but
one that feels necessary. Even though M*A*S*H
is ostensibly a comedy, it never shies away
from depicting the brutal realities of war.
The series finale of Merlin plays out like
a brutal tragedy. From the very beginning,
the show is centered around the friendship
between Arthur and Merlin. As Arthur ascends
the throne and heads off to adventure with
the rest of the knights of the round table,
the show’s primary interest doesn't
change. In the final episode, though,
Arthur is struck down, and Merlin is
unable to revive him. He's told that
Arthur will rise again, but neither Merlin
nor the audience gets to see that happen.
Instead, the episode follows Merlin as he spends
millennia waiting for his friend to come again.
He's an ageless, eternal being, doomed to be
traumatized by a past that he has no power to
change. While the rest of the characters
in Merlin get to live complete arcs,
the show's central figure must remain in stasis.
The life he leads now is one a life of waiting.
He's lost his best friend, and now, all he can do
is pray that he'll get to see him again… someday.
The ending of How I Met Your Mother was hugely
anticipated by the show's fans. That excitement
stemmed in part from the show's premise, which
suggests that eventually, Ted will get to the
part of the story that involves his wife. The
finale does indeed reveal their first meeting,
before offering an abbreviated look at
what his life with his kids' mother,
played by Cristin Milioti, went on to be like.
It's just as sweet and romantic as fans hoped for.
The episode ultimately reveals, however, that
the mother died in 2024. She and Ted built a life
together, but it wasn't one meant to last forever.
Although Milioti only plays a prominent role in
the final arc of the show's run, she made such an
enormous impression on audiences that her death
proved to be a deeply sad and divisive event. The
entire show builds up to the mother's arrival,
and when audiences finally meet her, she doesn't
disappoint — but the show's decisions might.
How I Met Your Mother's final episode became
further controversial for suggesting that,
after the mother's death, Ted ultimately
falls back in love with Robin. To many,
this choice rings hollow, in part because of all
the hype that had been built around the mother.
If you present a simple and factual account
of what happens at the end of The Americans,
it might not seem all that devastating. Philip
and Elizabeth, the Russian spies at the center
of the show, manage to safely return to the USSR
after spending years living as Americans. In
order to make their escape, though, they have to
give up the entire life they've built in the US.
Their daughter, who was supposed to
join them on their journey to the USSR,
decides to stay behind, and it's unclear
whether they'll ever see her again.
When you dig into the human emotion at the core of
this finale, its true tragedy is revealed. Philip
has to tell his best friend that he's been lying
to him for years, and entrust him with looking
after the son they're leaving behind. What's
more, the society they're returning to is on
the brink of collapse. All of the crimes and the
lies that the two of them have been caught up in,
all for the sake of their homeland, will have
been for nothing. They built their lives in
the US and were forced to abandon those lives
for a country they haven't lived in for years.
And then, at the end of it all, that failing
country makes it perfectly clear that it doesn't
actually care about them. It's a crushing
final blow for the show's protagonists.
The final episode of The Leftovers has a happy
ending, but it's one that comes after an enormous
amount of trauma. The finale is set more than
a decade in the future, as Nora lives a quiet,
remote life in Australia. That life faces a huge
disruption when Kevin, her former boyfriend and
the love of her life, shows up out of the blue.
The entire episode is built on the weight of
the history between these two characters, and
that history is more than a little grueling.
When they finally reconcile, it's a moment
of enormous relief, and a reminder of how
far they've both come. The Leftovers is set
in a world in which two percent of the world's
population has inexplicably vanished, and
the show's finale chooses not to provide any
firm answers about this. Instead, it suggests
that what matters is how its characters feel,
and whether or not they've been able
to overcome their struggles. Indeed,
Kevin and Nora have certainly struggled before,
but the finale suggests that maybe, just maybe,
there might be cause for hope. It's an
optimistic ending, but one that serves
to highlight the deep sadness that the two
of them have shared throughout the series.
BoJack Horseman's final episode opens with the
titular character being rescued from the pool
at his former house. He winds
up in prison for trespassing,
and finds that the routine his life takes on
in jail helps him in his battle with addiction.
The finale then leaps forward one year. BoJack
is released for Princess Carolyn's wedding,
where he sees all of his old friends again.
But it becomes increasingly clear that these
friendships, which have been the core
of the series, may not last forever.
BoJack is a better person than he was
when the show started, but he's done
irreparable harm to the people he's supposed
to care about most. They still love Bojack,
but they know that if they're looking
to build healthy lives for themselves,
they might have to leave him behind. As
Diane, BoJack's closest confidant, tells him:
"I think there are people that help you
become the person who you end up being,
and you can be grateful for them, even if they
were never meant to be in your life forever."
The finale of BoJack Horseman is about knowing
when relationships have run their course,
and allowing people to leave your
life, even if it hurts in the moment.
When They See Us has an ending that
could actually be described as happy.
The Central Park Five, who have spent years in
prison, are eventually exonerated for the crime
of sexually assaulting a woman, and the real
criminal is brought to justice. In the end,
their story is one of triumph, but
that triumph comes at an enormous cost.
The young kids at the core of the series
have been brutalized by a system that was
built to automatically assume the
worst of young Black men like them.
These characters have been traumatized, and
the fact that they are eventually exonerated
does not erase what has happened to them.
When They See Us sheds a light on the crime
that was perpetrated against these boys,
and what it reveals is devastating. They
were totally unable to defend themselves, and so
they were swallowed up by a vicious establishment.
The fact that they're spat out
again is little comfort to anyone.
A TV show about the AIDS crisis
was never going to be a great time,
but It's a Sin is still a particularly
horrifying reminder of what the early
days of AIDS were truly like in the U.K. The
show follows a group of young, gay Londoners
who are thrilled to be able to live their
lives as who they really are. Slowly, though,
the unfolding AIDS crisis invades and transforms
those lives, as well as the world around them.
By the end of the show, several of the main
characters have died, and the show's final
moments are rooted in the show's protagonist
succumbing to the virus. He was once vibrant,
cocky, and full of life, but he dies alone in his
childhood bedroom, cut off from his friends by his
panicked, homophobic mother. It's a Sin is about
what it meant to be gay during this era, and how
AIDS redefined an entire generation of people.
It's also about a few particular young men whose
lives are cut tragically short. The finale brings
this tragedy into sharp and unforgettable focus.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.